im chart so hat man sich eine schicke
neue straßenbeleuchtung gegönnt hier
stehen jetzt hochmoderne solarlampen in
dem dorf in mecklenburg vorpommern
mussten die uralt leuchten weichen damit
platz ist für energiesparende
solartechnik aber die schönen neuen
hightech lampen haben einen ganz
entscheidenden nachteil sie
funktionieren nicht richtig nachts gehen
hier nach ein paar stunden regelmäßig
die lichter aus find ich furchtbar die
kinder die früh zur schule gehen im
winter
die haben kein licht jetzt kommt mein
auto von hinten und sieht die kinder
nicht die fahnen sie nachher an weil was
sie hier fabrizieren ist ein schuss und
offen
das ist zu klein und zu mickrig und wir
haben nicht ewig zusammen sonnenschein
und und kann gar nicht funktionieren
immer wieder macht sich anwohner dieter
walter nachts auf den weg und zelten
nach welche lampen denn überhaupt
brennen mit absurd schlechten
ergebnissen an einem dezemberabend
leuchten von 31 lampen ganze 2 das ist
ja im grunde weiß dass unsere solar
technik hier eigentlich nicht
funktioniert wenn keine sonne scheint
ist auch kein strom da die lampen die
selten leuchten haben satte 111.000 euro
gekostet im zuständigen rathaus kann der
bürgermeister den ärger verstehen aber
erhält das projekt noch nicht für
gescheitert
also ich würde es nicht als platt als
fehlplanung hier so hinstellen es ist
war vielleicht auch mal ein versuch oder
versuche ist natürlich nun ja wie sagt
man so landläufig in die hose gegangen
oder ihn zumindest nicht optimal
gelaufen und unser ziel muss jetzt
einfach sein aber dass wir eine
vernünftige lösung finden dass im
nächsten winter oder zum herbst in das
auch den tadellos funktioniert die
schafe sind fassungslos wie lachs die
verwaltung mit der problematik umgeht
schließlich mussten sie selbst einen
teil der kosten übernehmen jeder
zwischen 600 und fast 2000 euro
wenn man über leistung bezahlt muss und
auch funktioniert das ist fakt alles
andere gilt nicht wir fühlen uns jetzt
richtig als versuchskaninchen
das funktioniert so nicht wir wollen
vernünftige straßen nicht für unser geld
die stadt will jetzt einen experten
einschalten der den fehler finden und
endlich licht ins dunkel bringen soll
damit die solarlampen endlich das tun
weshalb sie hier herum stehen leuchten